voilà bonjour je viens de dire vous êtes
devant l'hôpital où le président se
trouve actuellement être quel est le but
de cette visite
exactement un mirage me trouve
actuellement devant cet hôpital où
emmanuel macron a rencontré le personnel
hospitalier après comme vous l'avez dit
le décès d'un premier français âgé de 60
ans du coup rona virus il a rencontré
les médecins ils ont longuement discuté
sur le cas du corona à virus en france
il faut savoir que le but de cette
visite qui était tenu secret jusqu'à
présent et bien c'est de rassurer elle
les français de leur montrer que le
personnel hospitalier est pleinement
mobilisée il y avait en échange
justement entre les médecins et le
président de la république est
d'ailleurs accompagné par le ministre de
la santé
olivier ferrand et le personnel
hospitalier qui lui a fait état du
coronavirus en france je propose de les
écouter
je pense qu'il va y avoir une situation
à peu à l'italienne c'est à dire qu'en
fait là on a quand même des chaînes de
transmission autochtone c'est-à-dire les
cas français notamment patient qui est
décédé hier ici à la pitié plus le cas
qu'est ce qui t'a disait un lien ces
deux patients qui n'ont pas de liens
avec la chine
donc ça traduit le fait qu'une chaîne de
contenus des chaînes de transmission
autochtone en france et donc ça veut
dire que le virus circule déjà parmi le
virus les personnes qui sont décédées
disiez ne sont pas décédées directement
du virus alors allez-y
je trouve qu'effectivement les deux
personnes qui sont décédées en france
sont des personnes qui soient avait une
comorbidité par exemple comme le patient
chinois était décédée à bichat soit sont
décédés d'une autre pathologie
même s'il était affecté et dans un
contexte de colère la france beaucoup de
manifestations les médecins en tout cas
sur place ont tenu à alerter sur les
moyens dont il dispose et je vous
propose de les écouter ils avaient l'air
en tout cas inquiète le corps soignant
qui dans son ensemble
après tous les efforts nécessaires nous
sommes avec au bout oui mais on a besoin
d'un choc shop au catch up
d'attractivité il faut absolument pour
refinancer en d'urgence je suis pas là
pour moi d'accomplir et et je suis là
vous savez qui est derrière moi
l'ensemble du cours soit nous et on peut
pas se contenter les finalement je suis
désolé d'accord mais on est passé par un
angle déni après on a fait comme stable
maintenant il faut agir
alors moi le fond de ma pensée c'est que
kairos c'est le moment opportun et le
monde porte un pour le président la
république plage et même dans une
situation dont il n'est pas responsable
c'est maintenant il faut saisir
mais pas très bien j'ai entendu je pense
que je suis pas le seul ok très bien
mais je méritais notre fidèle
merci que vous voulez voir
mais il a un beau lui quand il a fallu
sauver notre dame il y avait beaucoup de
monde pour être élu là il faut sauver
l'hôpital public qui en train de flamber
à la même vitesse que contre l'ama
failli tomber ça s'est joué à rien et là
en ce moment ça se joue à rien une
enquête a été ouverte pour retracer le
parcours de cet homme âgé de 60 ans qui
est décédée hier il n'est pas le seul
il a également eu un touriste chinois de
80 ans qui est décédée également il ya
eu 4 guérison de l'autre côté si bête
ndiaye elle refuse de parler d'épidémie
en tout cas vous l'avez entendu le but
est de rassurer elle les français sur le
corps et la vidéo c'est évidemment
prouver que le personnalise pitallier
est pleinement mobilisé en tout cas
mobilisée à cent pour cent mais ils ont
également fait part de leurs inquiétudes
concernant les moyens dont ils
disposaient quoi qu'il en soit emmanuel
macron est toujours présent ici à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière il va
s'envoler dans quelques heures vers
naples pour rencontrer le premier
ministre josé paix compte et en italie
merci mona pour toutes ces précisions